some things we multiply they're actually
very easy to do remember I told you that
positions work hard so it can be lazy we
try and do as little work as possible so
let me just pop this out of the way
whenever you are multiplying by any of
these numbers and there are a few extra
ones as well but this is a really good
set to start with whenever you're
multiplying by these numbers here there
are some strategies or shortcuts you can
use that make things much simpler so let
me show you some of them 2 4 8 to start
with here I think most of us are pretty
good at doubling that's a skill you
start practicing very early on so we
double we know how to make something
twice as big and that's like manageable
numbers don't get like crazy out of
control like I'm some reason to do over
here if instead of asking you being
asked to multiply by 2 you get the
costume up on my for remember the 4 is 2
times 2 right so therefore you can
double but then you can just double
again and that'll get you up to 4 so
here's my strategy instead of thinking
okay what's the first and the second and
then the third and then the fourth
multiple I think about doubling doubling
is pretty easy to keep in my hair okay
not to be too boring though what do you
think I would say 4 8 4 double once I
get to 2 but doctor twice I get full
operation whoa ok now this is a really
sneaky one okay now doubling four times
is a great instinct because eight years
don't like this part but eight years uh
2 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 look there it is
4 times however what kind of operation
are we working with right now try to
avoid this is a multiplication right
multiplication even though it is 2 plus
2 plus 2 pursue 4 times what I'm
interesting is not how much they have
how they multiply right so even though
this is true what's more useful to me is
how do you choose do I have to multiply
by yeah so I'm going to do it three
times right do you see that so how many
times should I double three times top on
that
okay fantastic so two four and eight
they're kind of like a little family
together we get to ten
we are you gonna go in a different
direction now if I asked you okay can
you tell me don't shout it out yet but
can you tell me what six times ten is
okay I think most of you know the answer
quite quickly put your hands out okay
how would you think about how would you
work out the odds are if you didn't know
it straight away if you didn't know that
it was in fact 60 okay how would we go
about it what what process would we go
through yet
okay now you're already going into this
shortcut right now I want to know why
that shortcut works we tell you how I
was by numbers I go through my tail I
know my table was peoples let them hear
my table is 60 which is the actual
answer I'm after right that was okay
because I knew what that number was and
as you can see as we've mentioned in
fact all I need to do is from
bioregional levels just pop a zero
that's nice if you have a number right
so I'm going to insert zero on the end
it's Malayalee faster but you know what
is lots of numbers that I don't know the
times tables for for instance I don't
know about you but I don't know my 217
times tables very well 217 434 you stop
there right if I won my 10 I could know
this gonna be 2107 right just okay now
hundreds in the same family what do you
think I could do about the 100
very good because multiplying by a
hundred is just like we saw before it's
multiplying by 10 twice notice that
right multiplied by 10 once then do it
again so I can it send zero zero on the
end now we're on us again to you five
and nine even though they don't look
like it the strategy the shortcut I'm
going to show you is actually the same
family this is 10100 M
okay five and ten they are related to
each other
house five related to ten yeah very good
five is exactly half of 10 okay so since
it's half of 10 what I can do is if I
know what my number is
well then it is what's half of that
number and then multiply it by ten does
that make sense
I'm doing those two steps so for
instance if I wanted to multiply six by
five okay I already know what the answer
is because again you guys know your long
table was very well
but I know that I could do it as well
top of six which is off of six is just
three okay and then I add the zero on
right you guys are so pretty right on my
next day okay so the way I say this is
half in a buck
and then just like we did before you can
set this here on the end multiply by ten
okay I'll let the sneakiest one to last
we're multiplying by nine now I said to
you before it's in the same family as
ten I was nine connected to ten yeah
okay I've numbered funnily enough it
kind of will and I will show you in
future how it works
you're right though here's a bit of her
what is half a two hundred and seventeen
you don't and you get like bits of
numbers and we will talk about those
bits of numbers later on this year I'm
so glad you asked that
now sorry we will come back to life
right nine is just one less than ten
right one less than ten so I'm going to
write this strategy down and then you
try to explain it right here's what we
do multiply by ten that's the first
thing you do and we already know it
that's super easy to do you almost don't
even have to think
but I do you multiply by ten yeah
brother yes
very good so you first of all father -
and secondly you not explained this in a
second if you like what okay
you're then going to that's just - they
just confuse so I just hear hey we're
gonna multiply by ten and then we're
gonna subtract the original number okay
now just before I show you how this
works let's just confirm that it
actually does what we were working with
six before well we now you already know
what six times nine is I've written it
on the board you insert the zero on the
end which is the first step that gets
you to 60 and then you subtract the
original are 660 take away six does it
work it does work right now the big
question why why does it work there's
anyone and it's okay so you can't think
of one laughter I'll put you on the spot
but does they don't want to give a
suggestion on not just like that it
works but why might work yeah and
because it's all additions and the
opposite of addition is subtraction so
if you take the way you would leave the
same less nine very good so if you did
catch that 9:00 right it's like add nine
times right at nine times and you get
there just like we found out before but
adding it nine times is the same as
adding a ten times and then coming back
one do you notice that it's like you get
all the way to 60 the tip one I mean
just say look just you you wait a bit
your father just come back they want to
offer another suggestion that's a great
way to understand
okay interesting so in case you didn't
catch what that was six times nine we go
back one number which is five okay so
that's back for a number from this and
then what you want is a pair of digits
that adds up to nine and then a pair
that that is five and four in this case
I guess if you went well let's say they
looted from the mall let's do eight
times nine
I guess if I were trying to use that
strategy I'd go back one number which is
seven and then I think food
what's the digit that adds up to nine if
I use those two and 72 which is indeed
that multiple okay up there are things I
like about that and there are things I
like about this method it's kind of nice
to have lots and lots of strategies in
your toolbox so you can choose whichever
one feels worse